hello my name is danny and i'm a
developer here at sharpie
and i'm going to be talking about the
idea of reusability
um
so because i'm as lazy as the next
person i think one of the most wonderful
moments when using angular
is uh seeing a mock-up and realizing
that you can implement
one of the features in it with basically
a line of code
in this example that you're probably
some of you are probably familiar with
from the angular homepage
you get a full-fledged tab interface
complete with styles and markup and
interaction
with basically
a single line of code
or a couple lines of code
um
so angular gives you a taste of that
right out of the box with directives
like ng repeat
but to really have those moments
repeatedly requires you as a developer
or as a team of developers to
assemble kind of your own collection of
these reusable components
and directives
so
the idea that you should create reusable
components is not really all that novel
or controversial
in fact it's pretty foundational to
angular and a lot of other popular web
frameworks
and they all have their own unique
approaches to actually building these
components
um which i'm not really going to go into
in this talk um
but overall it's pretty clear that
the web standards are evolving with an
eye towards this idea of
a modular reusable component
architecture
and the rationale behind that is is
actually very clear
it's probably safe to say that the
majority of the functionality that you
implement
in an application
uh has been done before in some capacity
uh either by you or someone in your
organization or in your in your network
and that's a good thing it means that
we're designing interfaces that are
consistent with kind of established
patterns and principles
the promise of this component
architecture then is that you get to
spend all your time doing the fun unique
interesting stuff in less time on the
stuff that
has been done before
so uh
but i've been thinking a lot lately
about the process of actually assembling
uh that collection right
um
that collection of reusable stuff
uh essentially how do you as an
individual or as a team get to a place
that
building an application is just sort of
taking a bunch of building blocks
putting them together and then getting
the sum total of that functionality
um mostly or because i i don't think
it's quite as straightforward as it at
first seems right
um
you might think kind of based on all
this stuff that you should just make
every piece of code you ever write
reusable um and sort of applicable in
other contexts
um
so that you would get as quickly as
possible to that point of
building an application fully out of
these building blocks
but i'm going gonna argue that it's
that's just not really a realistic
approach um
and then
try to come up with kind of a better way
of thinking about it
so
first off
um it's always more work to make a thing
reusable right
um
that's because in addition to just
making it work in that particular
little isolated context you then have to
think about how do i make it work in a
whole host of other ones that i don't
even know about um
you know that involves both anticipating
things that will go wrong in those other
contexts
and uh
thinking through the different
requirements and customizations that
might be desirable in those other
contexts
so given that it it follows that you
it's just not tenable to make everything
that you do reusable right
there's some selection process that goes
into designing which things to invest
that time
to make reusable
secondly
it's impossible to predict the future
requirements of a particular project
or the other projects that might use the
thing that you you've
made
so this makes it very difficult to
design a thing that's just 100 plug and
play whenever you might need it down the
line or whenever someone else might need
it
and thirdly
making a component reusable
it it entails a kind of freezing where
you are taking some features
um
of all the features you could make uh
you're taking some and saying i'm gonna
support these uh and then there's others
that you decide to not include right um
so
the more you freeze a thing to make it
reusable the less you can kind of do
that ad hoc customization
uh without having thought about it
beforehand
so um
i wanted to kind of briefly discuss two
examples of reusable components that
terpene
um
through this
kind of viewpoint
first off we have the aforementioned
directive cb tooltip
which i think is actually a very good
example of when to make
a reusable component
you can see right there as an example
uh
you know
fairly straightforward tooltip everyone
knows what a tooltip is probably
um
but the actual implementation of a
robust tooltip system
uh is a little
more difficult than you might think as
mentioned you know there's like sort of
uh there's different enhancements that
you can add that make it
much more usable
um
so
uh
let's see sorry
um
but oh yeah so it's probably a thing
that you only want to really do once
given the amount of work
but it's also thing that you're probably
just going to reuse over and over in
many applications
it's a very core interaction element
so the expected reuse is very high
so i feel like there's this kind of
weird calculation that is
that goes into evaluating whether to
turn a thing into a reusable component
um
and and that is does the amount of work
to implement it
um
coupled with kind of the expected reuse
uh justify
the work to make it reusable right
you're sort of comparing these two
things
um
and it's i guess a pretty classic
upfront cost versus long-term benefit
type question
um
and in this case or i think tool tips
pretty solidly in favor making them
reusable
um
some other considerations are that tool
tips are a very established interaction
paradigm
you just don't see a whole lot of
innovation in the tooltip space so
it's probably a feature that uh you can
reasonably expect to remain consistent
in the future wherever you might want to
implement them
mobile's gonna change that that is true
um
that is a good point
uh so and lastly uh
butt related tool tips are probably
going to be relatively self-contained um
it's it's kind of hard to imagine
uh
you know something else hooking into the
state of a tool tip to control itself
like but at that point you're not really
doing a tool tip you're doing something
else um so the customization
requirements are probably gonna be very
minimal
um and here you can see the actual
implement implementation of cb tooltip
um
very simple very easy to understand
pretty minimal required configuration
so
on the flip side
we have uh
a component that i made called
horizontal bar chart
um
so when i was implementing a page in one
of our products i i noticed these like a
couple
bar charts and i thought to myself
that is an opportunity to make a thing
reusable
um
so i made this directive that took in an
array of objects and
showed uh you know a variable number of
uh properties as columns
and had one column or one property that
decided the width of the bar
um
you know one or two more little things
added to it
um
and it all went great
for a short period of time
um
so though this was actually reused
successfully elsewhere in our product
i now don't really believe that it was
totally a uh an appropriate thing to
make reusable
so first off the upfront work of making
a bar chart is pretty minimal like edits
at its root you could do it with a ng
repeat and like some css
um it might be a little annoying to have
to do it over and over but it's just not
a very complex visualization to
implement um so that sort of upfront
implementation cost is is much smaller
um
and so even though we do use bar charts
here somewhat frequently the cost of
implementing each one doesn't quite add
up as much
as it did with the tooltip
so also you'll notice here that
reusability
is not only an initial cost
so if you ever have to go back and kind
of maintain or update the component
because
requirements have changed or you've
encountered a new context where it
doesn't work
i think an estimate of that work to the
best of your ability at the time should
factor into that that decision of
whether uh it's worth it to make the
thing reusable
um
so i didn't realize just how much and
how often our bar charts are kind of
customized
so i had no real way of kind of
predicting the future requirements of
the directive
and this resulted in some kind of weird
hacks to conditionally include certain
functionality in some cases
um
that aren't really that pretty
and here you can see it in action kind
of complete with this laundry list of
things that tell it how to behave in
this specific
uh
context
and just to give a little more clarity
on kind of what
ended up being
or complicated about it i guess
here are sort of two examples of the
directive or the component um so these
are the things that it was really built
to support just sort of arbitrary
numbers of columns you know one two or
one two three um relative r width um
sorting based on something
but down here you can see some of the
stuff that started to kind of stretch it
pretty thin
there's optional column headers that use
other directives
there was sort of this
it's hard to see but there's a
functionality to kind of like decide
which bars you want to include
which is its own directive
and then there's sort of different
filters were applying to the numbers
or the
data
so those are also you know custom
filters so just figuring out how to sort
of pack all this configurability and
customization into a single
originally very simple directive
proved to be a bit of a challenge
um
so i think if i were implementing the
bar chart now i would either not
abstract it into a component or
maybe try to think a little more about
separating it into separate things that
do these kind of custom things
specifically
rather than trying to make this
monolithic big thing that does
everything
so
i think the big takeaways for me so far
in thinking about this stuff are
um first off
just
take some time to think about this stuff
uh
you know
it's it's easy to just sort of either go
full on implementing something and not
even thinking about reusability at all
or just sort of take that that
that
approach at the beginning where you
you're thinking oh i should make
everything possible reusable um but i
think you know to maximize your time and
and get the best utility out of the kind
of stuff that angular offers
um
it's important to kind of consider how
hard it is to implement this thing each
time
how often you would reasonably expect to
reuse it in
other products or other people to use it
and then weigh both of those
against both the initial cost of making
it reusable and then to the best of your
ability kind of the
ways in which you might imagine it being
customized and configured down the line
and that should kind of factor into that
cost of reusability
second
i would be cautious about making early
stage things reusable
um
because you just might kind of waste a
lot of effort on a thing that just is
never used again
um
or you might spend all of your time
hacking it to adapt to these changing
requirements in the future
um i think it's probably often better to
wait for a thing to solidify and just
have some established utility before you
spend the time and effort to make it
into like a nicely packaged directive or
component
and lastly
uh
uh i would watch out for situations that
kind of require excessive configuration
to provide
basic functionality
um
so anytime you're kind of nesting a
bunch of directives or
you
require a huge number of attributes to
tell a thing how to behave in this
particular context
you should probably be wary of spending
time making that thing reusable
um
just because that's you know your time
is better spent on the other parts of
your application probably
so that's all i've got so far on this um
if anyone has any thoughts or questions
or anything
oh i'll take them now and here's my
twitter
so the situation that you're describing
about it's really interesting
um
so like one of the interesting that i
faced or
i was not fully purpose but like
i really feel that the thing
about horizontal bar charts
i've seen and used and kind of been a
part of
have more taking the approach of like
plug-ins like maybe if we get to those
type of play so you don't have like if
you want to use this module you don't
get a lot of code
because it's so big
so you know like make this core
that's just giving you the mixed
efficiency if you need more things
kind of group them and like include them
maybe to require just kind of system or
you know some something similar so like
if you want
like basic rendering then you want icon
based things or you want if you want
some other style like groups of
functionalities you can like have those
um that kind of work well for the base
but
um no i mean i think that that's
definitely a uh a viable avenue for
approaching this yeah i also i mean you
know
i also question whether you know like
what the right thing to do here was
actually um
because
i i think the main problem was the was
once i made the reusable thing i then
tried to throw everything into it in the
in the future um
so i didn't really imagine at the time
that there would be this configuration
and customization um
so yeah i think that's sort of the
thought i have about that
totally open to keep that came out of
that
uh how like what is the um requirements
just
like to make it
like is it like a time span like for
spring art is like
because sometimes you just want to
implement an idea just to implement it
but
when does it when this decision is
actually actually quite fast
um you know uh
it it probably varies that's a compound
answer but uh
yeah
i mean i think uh
like i said at the um and like
i i probably in the future i'm gonna be
a little hesitant when i'm first doing
something like prototyping stuff to
really spend much time being like oh
hmm how can i like make this
accommodate being used in this other
product or like this other situation
um
and spend a little more time just
making the thing right there and
achieving the goals of that prototype um
and then if maybe
you know a second time or third time or
fourth time we
we reuse that thing or we see it's
it's it's going to be a thing that is
valuable in the future then you can kind
of spend some time on that
um you know there's no like hard or fast
rules but um
i think it's it's something to just at
least think about and
uh and
consider
at the beginning
good question uh so you talked a lot
about reusability but there's a thing
focused on directly specifically right
in your workload you guys also factor in
reusability and
yeah uh
we do have that um
i mean like harry mentioned we have a
like a feed service i think that is
shared across our products
um
yeah i mean i think you know i think
this applies often to that kind of stuff
too
um
i think those maybe those patterns are
like you know services and factories and
stuff are kind of patterns that
are built around reusability in a
certain way um whereas i think
directives it's very easy to
um you know do something that isn't a
reusable component
and
then you have to convert it to that you
know i don't think that made sense but
um
yeah
okay
so um with the bar chart uh
did the variations on the bar chart
exist prior and you were trying to like
find like before and then expand on it
or was it like you built a core and then
and then like through like design new
updates to the bar chart happen and then
you had to address those updates
um
i'd say
two of the ones listed here existed very
quickly the
the icons and the custom data filters
and
in the original design i
i sort of accommodated those
customizations um
through you know i mean it worked uh
i don't think it was the greatest code
that i've ever written
um
but i think that maybe should have been
kind of a clue that further things were
coming down the line and it and it
really broke when
or
it didn't break but it just required a
huge amount of work to get it to work
with
um the stuff where you can just sort of
dynamically exclude different things
yeah um
for reasons that are probably not that
interesting to go into but uh
yeah i think i think
there were clues at the start that this
was gonna be a thing that we were gonna
use a lot but like decide to make
arbitrary little changes to every time
we use it and
um
i think that should have been probably a
clue to me that
to be a little wary of it yeah
so it sounds like you're building this
in an agile process
uh
yeah i mean we have like our six week
cycle kind of
process
um i have a couple of
things to say about this is it was very
interesting
here but um
it sounds like you're a victim of your
own success with this widget uh kind of
places saying that if you want to get
something done give it to a busy man
and you get a successful widget so
if you can do that but they can't why
not give it a ton more things to do
and it sounds like this gold plating
basically destroyed the cohesiveness of
the region yeah um
and i think
you know
so you're sort of saying that it was
designed to do a thing
and then
other things were just why don't we do
this
that made the design bad um
yeah i think that's totally the case um
but
i guess maybe
the only thing that i that i think about
that is uh
and it's it's impossible to like i said
to predict that stuff um so this is just
like a fact of life in a lot of types of
uh
programming projects um
it but it's worth thinking about and
doing the best uh job you can to kind of
predict it
and like i said you know there maybe
were clues that oh we're gonna keep
wanting to do these weird things um
i don't know if that makes sense yes
agile would have like say
um maybe it's time for a spike or a
re-engineering of something like that
too yeah
yeah and that's i mean i think you know
and there's also limits that you know
javascript is not the most
object-oriented language it
may have ended up not using the
appropriate design panel yeah that's
totally true
um i'm gonna do
maybe two more
and then get to our next two talks
uh yeah
um so
in related to um
is there a way so i haven't done too
much with angular
is there a way to like
because it seems like you could
componentize part of it to like almost
create like a hybrid where there's like
the full component that does like some
of the bar chart stuff with like um you
know the columns and the chart and the
width of the bar um but then like on top
of that depending on the context and
where this component lands there's like
more customized thing with like the
icons and stuff so like you layer it so
you have the core so you can repeat that
as many times as you want but then you
have like this additional way you can
and on top that
based on context you can very much
customize and whatever but the core
stays and that's reusable i don't know
if that's a thing that you can do but
yeah i mean i think that that kind of
goes to what you're saying about the uh
plug-in style um
i think the problem that i ran into was
that
excuse me uh
some of the other kind of components and
directives and stuff that i was relying
on weren't designed with that in mind
either and i think to get that because
then you just run into kind of weird
scoping issues and
uh you know
if if you have two isolate scopes on the
same
uh element
that's not allowed um obviously so
i don't know yeah i think that that
that's probably the right solution in
this instance um
but i think it requires a little more
thought
what's that i wasn't sure if it's
something you can do in angular or not
yeah
i'm not sure off the top of my head to
give like a detailed authoritative
answer but it's definitely something to
think about
how does angular compare to your old
framework in the ease of making these
reusable components are you able to work
faster yeah definitely um
i think in the old framework we
weren't so concerned with this kind of
stuff um
there wasn't so much of a like an idiom
around you know really modular reusable
components um it was more like if we
needed that something you just added it
on like piled it on
um and we ended up with some
uh
pretty ludicrous files that like no one
knew how to read anymore
so
uh yeah i find angular i think
uh
kind of the the
one of the original points was that
angular and these kind of frameworks
this is like a a very foundational
paradigm so it encourages it more than
maybe
um other frameworks might
last question yeah do you communicate
with designers about components
do you communicate with designers about
components you already built and ready
to use
yeah um
yeah i mean so i think uh that's that's
an interesting question too
uh
because designers probably
often have some sense of what might
change in the future uh you know like
you know these are often designed kind
of decisions to include these things um
yeah i mean we work very closely with
our designers um
and i think
i probably in this instance could have
sort of
asked more questions up front to the
designer and thought hey
is this probably the way we're going to
keep using bar charts in the future and
all these other products and maybe
gotten an answer that way
but
live and learn
cool thank you